طبعا
[Silence]
الله
اول
[Silence]
‏I
استووادوا
استووا
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك اياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ومن يسلم وجهه الى الله وهو محسن فقد
استمسك بالعروه الوثقى
والى الله عاقبه الامور
ومن كفر فلا يحزنك كفره
الينا مرجعهم فننبئهم بما عملوا ان الله
عليم بذات الصدور
نمتعهم قليلا ثم نضطرهم الى عذاب غليظ
ولئن سالتهم من خلق السماوات والارض
ليقولن الله
قل الحمد لله بل اكثرهم لا يعلمون
ولله ما في السماوات والارض ان الله هو
الغني الحميد
ولو ان ما في الارض من شجره اقلام والبحر
يمده من بعده سبعه ابحر ما نفذت كلمات
الله
ان الله عزيز حكيم
ما خلقكم ولا بعثكم الا كنفس واحده ان
الله سميع بصير
الم تر ان الله يولج الليل في النهار
ويولج النهار في الليل وسخر الشمس والقمر
وسخر الشمس والقمر كل يجري الى اجل مسم
وان الله بما تعملون خبير
ذلك بان الله هو الحق وانما يدعون من دونه
الباطل وان الله هو العلي الكبير
الم تر ان الفلك تجري في البحر بنعمه الله
ليريكم من اياته ان في ذلك لايات لكل صبار
شكور
واذا غشيهم موج كالظلل دعوا الله مخلصين
له الدين
فلما نجاهم الى البر فمنهم مقتصد وما يجحد
باياتنا الا كل ختار كفور
يا ايها الناس يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم
واخشوا يوما
واخشوا يوما لا يجزي والد عن ولده ولا
مولود هو جاز عن والده شيئا ان وعد الله
حق فلا تغرنكم
الحياه الدنيا ولا يغرنكم
بالله الغرور
ان الله عنده علم الساعه وينزل الغيث
ويعلم ما في الارحام
وما تدري نفس ماذا تكسب غدا وما تدري نفس
باي ارض تموت
ان الله عليم خبير
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم
م
تنزيل الكتاب لا ريب فيه من رب العالمين
ام يقولون افتراه
بل هو الحق من ربك لتنذر قوما ما اتاهم من
نذير من قبلك لعلهم يهتدون
الله الذي خلق السماوات والارض وما بينهما
في سته ايام ثم استوى على العرش ما
من دونه من ولي ولا شفيع
افلا تتذكرون
يدبر الامر من السماء الى الارض ثم يعرج
اليه في يوم كان مقداره
في يوم كان مقداره الف سنه مما تعدون
ذلك عالم الغيب والشهاده العزيز الرحيم
الذي احسن كل شيء خلقه وبدا خلق الانسان
من طين
ثم جعل نسله من سلاله من ماء
مهين
ثم سواه ونفخ فيه من روحه
ثم سواه ونفخ فيه من روحه وجعل لكم السمع
والابصار
والافئده قليلا ما تشكرون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وقالوا ائذا ضللنا في الارض اانا لفي خلق
جديد بل هم بلقاء ربهم كافرون قل يتوفاكم
ملك الموت الذي وكل بكم ثم الى ربكم
ترجعون
ولو ترى اذ المجرمون ناكسوا رؤوسهم عند
ربهم ربنا ابصرنا وسمعنا
ربنا ابصرنا وسمعنا فارجعنا نعمل صالحا
انا موقنون
ولو شئنا لاتينا كل نفس هداها ولكن حق
القول مني لاملان جهنم من الجنه والناس
اجمعين
فذوقوا بما نسيتم لقاء يومكم هذا نسيناكم
وذوقوا عذاب الخلد بما كنتم تعملون
انما يؤمن باياتنا الذين اذا ذكروا بها
خروا سجدا
وسبحوا بحمد ربهم وهم لا تستكبرون
الله اكبر
[Silence]
تتجافى جنوبهم عن المضاجع يدعون ربهم خوفا
وطمعا ومما رزقناهم ينفقون
فلا تعلم نفس ما اخفي لهم من قره اعين
جزاء بما كانوا يعملون
افمن كان مؤمنا كمن كان فاسقا لا يستوون
اما الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فلهم
جنات ماوى نزلا بما كانوا يعملون
واما الذين فسقوا فماواهم النار
كلما ارادوا ان يخرجوا منها اعيدوا فيها
وقيل لهم ذوقوا عذاب النار الذي كنتم به
تكذبون
ولنذيقنهم
من العذاب الادنى دون العذاب الاك اكبر
لعلهم يرجعون
ومن اظلم ممن ذكر بايات ربه ثم اعرض عنها
انا من المجرمين منتقمون
ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب فلا تكن في مريه
من لقائه
وجعلناه هدى لبني اسرائيل
وجعلنا منهم ائمه
يهدون بامرنا لما صبروا وكانوا باياتنا
يوقنون
ان ربك هو يفصل بينهم يوم القيامه فيما
كانوا فيه يختلفون
اولم يهد لهم كم اهلكنا من قبلهم من
القرون يمشون في مساكنهم
ان في ذلك لايات افل لا يسمعون
اولم يروا انا نسوق الماء الى الارض الجرز
فنخرج به زرعا تاك فنخرج به زرعا تاكل منه
انعامهم وانفسهم
افلا يبصرون
ويقولون متى هذا الفتح ان كنتم صادقين قل
يوم الفتح لا ينفع ع الذين كفروا ايمانهم
ولا هم ينظرون
فاعرض عنهم وانتظر
انهم
منتظرون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده لك الحمد
[Silence]
الله
الله كده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها النبي اتق الله ولا تطع الكافرين
والمنافقين
ان الله كان عليما حكيما واتبع ما يوحى
اليك من ربك ان الله كان بما تعملون خبيرا
وتوكل على الله وكفى بالله وكيلا ما جعل
الله لرجل من قلبين في جوفه وما جعل
ازواجكم اللائي
تظاهرون منهن امهاتكم
وما جعل ادعياء ءكم ابناءكم
ذلكم قولكم بافواهكم
والله يقول الحق وهو يهدي السبيل
ادعوهم لابائهم هو اقسط عند الله
ادعوهم لابائهم
هو اقسط عند الله
فان لم تعلموا اباءهم
فاخوانكم في الدين ومواليكم
وليس عليكم جناح فيما اخطاتم به ولكن ما
تعمدت قلوبكم وكان الله غفورا رحيما
النبي اولى بالمؤمنين من انفسهم
وازواجه امهاتهم
واولو الارحام بعضهم اولى ببعض في كتاب
الله من المؤمنين والمهاجرين الا ان
تفعلوا الى اوليائكم
معروفا
كان ذلك في الكتاب مستورا
واذ اخذنا من النبيين ميثاقهم ومنك ومن
نوح وابراهيم وموسى وعيسى ابن مريم واخذنا
منهم ميثاقا غليظا ليسال الصادقين عن
صدقهم واعد للكافرين عذابا اليما.
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم اذ جاءتكم
جنود فارسلنا عليهم ريحا وجنودا لم تروها
وكان الله بما تعملون بصيرا اذ جاؤوكم
من فوقكم ومن اسفل منكم واذ زاغت الابصار
وبلغت القلوب الحناجر
وبلغت القلوب الحناجر وتظنون
بالله الظنو
هنالك ابتلي المؤمنون وزلزلوا زلزالا
شديدا
واذ يقول المنافقون والذين في قلوبهم
مرض ما وعدنا الله ورسوله الا غرورا
واذ قالت طائفه
منهم يا اهل يثرب لا مقا لكم فارجعوا
ويستاذن فريق منهم النبي يقولون ان بيوتنا
عوره وما هي بعوره ان يريدون الا فرارا
ولو دخلت عليهم من اقطارها ثم سئلوا
الفتنه لاتوها وما تلبثوا بها الا يسيرا
ولقد كانوا وعاهدوا الله من قبل لا يولون
الادبار
وكان عهد الله مسؤولا
قل لن ينفعكم الفرار ان فررتم من الموت او
القتل واذا لا تمتعون الا قليلا قل من ذا
الذي يعصمكم من الله ان اراد بكم سوءا او
اراد بكم رحمه
ولا يجدون لهم من دون الله وليا ولا نصيرا
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قد يعلم الله المعوقين والقائلين
لاخوانه
م هلم الينا ولا ياتون الباس الا قليلا
قد يعلم الله المعوقين منكم والقائلين
لاخوانهم هلم الينا ولا ياتون الباس الا
قليلا
اشحه عليكم فاذا جاء الخوف رايتهم ينظرون
اليك تدور اعينهم كالذي يغشى عليه من
الموت
فاذا ذهب الخوف سلقوكم بالسنه حداد اشحه
على الخير اولئك لم يؤمنوا فاحبط الله
اعمالهم وكان ذلك على الله يسيرا
يحسبون الاحزاب لم يذهبوا وان ياتي
الاحزاب يودوا لو انهم بادون في الاعراب
يسالون عن انبائكم
ولو كانوا فيكم ما قاتلوا الا قليلا
لقد كان لكم في رسول الله اسوه حسنه لمن
كان يرجو الله واليوم الاخر وذكر الله
كثيرا
ولما راى المؤمنون الاحزاب قالوا هذا ما
وعدنا الله ورسوله وصدق الله ورسوله وما
زادهم الا ايمانا
وتسليما
من المؤمنين رجال صدقوا ما عاهدوا الله
عليه
فمنهم من قضى نحبه ومنهم من ينتظر وما
بدلوا تبديلا
ليج يجزي الله الصادقين بصدقهم ويعذب
المنافقين ان شاء
الله كان غفورا رحيما
ورد الله الذين كفروا بغيظهم لم ينالوا
خيرا وكفى الله المؤمنين القتال
وكان الله قويا عزيزا
وانزل الذين ظاهروهم من اهل الكتاب من
صياصيهم وقذف في قلوبهم الرعب
وقذف في قلوبهم الرعب فريقا
تقتلون وتاسرون فريقا
واورثكم ارضهم وديارهم واموالهم وارضا لم
تطؤوها
وكان الله على كل شيء قديرا
يا ايها النبي قل لازواجك ان كنتن
تردن الحياه الدنيا وزينتها فتعالين
فتعالين امتعكن
واسرحكن
سراحا جميلا
وان كنتن تردن الله ورسوله والدار الاخره
فان الله اعد المحسنات منكن اجرا عظيما
يا نساء النبي من يات منكن بفاحشه مبينه
يضاعف لها العذاب ضعفين
وكان ذلك على الله يسيرا ومن يقنت منكن
لله ورسوله وتعمل صالحا نؤتها اجرها مرتين
واعتدنا لها رزقا كريما
يا نساء النبي لستن كاحد من النساء ان
اتقيتن
فلا تخضعن بالقول فيطمع الذي في قلبه مرض
وقلن قولا معروفا
وقرن في بيوتكن ولا تبرجن تبرج الجاهليه
يه الاولى واقمنا الصلاه واتينا الزكاه
واطعنا الله ورسوله
انما يريد الله ليذهب عنكم الرجس اهل
البيت ويطهركم
تطهيرا
الله اكبر
سمع سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سنه صلى الله عليه وسلم تراويح
صلى الله عليه وسلم
قيام امام ينصرف
كتبت له قيام ليله
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
adday
atay
[Silence]
‏and come back with usay
with us anday with anday
at
‏again because صلى الله عليه وسلم tells
us
وتران في ليله person make صلاه inmong
toay after
that is not
you pray it you don'tay again
[Silence]
نخب
صلاه
make
bothمay
until you make ‏with anday at you canay
as much as you want make again if come
back at i am you pray two two two sets
of two and you don't make withter a
second time because we don't make
withter twice otherwise it really
defeats the purpose of witter witht is
an od number if you do it twice no
longer number
ان شاء الله
برض هنقوم عشان احنا هنوتر بالليل عشان
لما يشوفونا
يمشي وبرضه اذا ما بدكم تصلوا الحينكم هيك
كمان هيك او هيك
حفاظ
الشيخ ضاري والدكتور عاصم وتر ان شاء
‏make
الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ويل لكل همزه لمزا
الذي جمع مالا وعددا
يحسب ان ماله
اخلدا كال الا لينبذن
في الحطمه
وما
ادراكما الحطمه نار
الموقد
التي تطلع على الافئده
انها
عليهم
مؤصدا
في عمد
ممددا
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ارايت الذي يكذب بالدين
فذلك الذي يدع اليتيم
ولا يحض على طعام المسكين
فويل للمصلين
الذين هم عن صلاتهم سابوا
الذين هم يراءون
ويمنعون
الماعون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
[Arabic recitation]
الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت
وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما ما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذ
واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا من جاى منك الا اليك
اللهم اننا عبيدك بنو عبيدك بنو
امائك نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل
فينا قضاؤك نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به
نفسك او انزلته
في كتابك
او علمته احدا من خلقك او استاثرت به في
علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منهما ما جهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسيناه
وعلمنا الحكمه منه اللهم
اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات
وترك المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا
وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت
بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم احينا ما كانت الحياه خيرا لنا
وتوفنا اذا كانت الوفاه خيرا لنا اللهم
اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه في
غزه وفلسطين
وفي كل مكان حيث حلوا ربنا اجعل اجعلهم
على عدوهم ظاهرين
قاهرين
عزيزين
منصورين
عالين
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من شرورهم
ونجعلك في نحورهم
ربنا
زلزل اركانهم
وصدع بنيانهم
واقتل اجنادهم
واقذف في قلوبهم الهلع والفزع والذل
والهوان
اللهم واجعل قتلاهم في النيران
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
اشهد ان لا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
سبحان
[Silence]
يعني